INFORMATION IS CONTINUING TO
COME OUT AND OBVIOUSLY WE'LL
KEEP TRACK OF IT.
THERE WAS ANOTHER BIG STORY
TODAY.
IN DECEMBER 2018, AN IRAQ WAR
VETERAN CALLED PAUL WHEELING
FLEW TO MOSCOW TO ATTEND THE
WEDDING OF A FRIEND HE HAD KNOWN
IN THE MARINE CORPS.
DAYS AFTER HE ARRIVED, SIX DAYS
WE THINK HE WAS ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH SPYING.
RESTAURANT AUTHORITIES CLAIMED
HE HAD ACCEPTED A FLASH DRIVE
LOADED WITH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION FROM AN INTEL AGENT
IN RUSSIA.
HE WAS PUT ON TRIAL AND HE WAS
SENTENCED TO 16 YEARS IN PRISON
FOR ESPIONAGE.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING HE
CLAIMED HE WAS SET UP.
HE SAID HE WAS IN MOSCOW ON
VACATION.
AT THE WEDDING.
HE WASN'T SPYING ON RUSSIA.
WE TEND TO BELIEVE HIM ALTHOUGH
WE CAN'T KNOW FOR SURE, HOW
COULD WE?
BUT EITHER WAY, WHETHER HE WAS
SET UP OR ACTUALLY SPYING ON
RUSSIA, PAUL'S CASE WOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR ANY AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT.
HERE YOU HAVE A MAN WHO HAS
ACTIVELY SERVED THE UNITED
STATES IN THE MARINE CORPS AND
POSSIBLY IS AN INTEL ASSET IN A
HOSTILE FOREIGN COUNTRY, THAT
MAN IS LANGUISHING -- IN A
PRISON CELL.
IT TURNS OUT THEY DIDN'T MEAN A
WORD OF IT TO BRING HIM HOME.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY HAD SECURED
THE RELEASE OF A PRISON IN
RUSSIA, A FEMALE BASKETBALL
PLAYER, BRITTNEY GREENER.
IN EXCHANGE THEY HADDED OVER AN
ARMS DEALLER -- VIKTOR BOUT.
>> VIKTOR IN MY EYES SOMEONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS MEN ON THE
FACE OF THE EARTH.
>> ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> MIKE BRAWN, FORMER CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS FOR THE U.S. DRUG
ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATION TOLD
US HE FIRST EXPLODED ON THE
SCENE IN WAR-TORN AFRICA IN THE
LATE 1980.
ELEVATING BLOODY CONFLICTS FROM
MACHETES AND SINGLE SHOT RIFLES
TO --
>> AK47'S, BY THE TONS OF
THOUSANDS.
>> HE TRANSFORMED THESE YOUNG
ADOLESCENT WARRIORS INTO
INSIDIOUS, MINDLESS KILLING
MACHINES WHICH OPERATED WITH
ASSEMBLY LINE EFFICIENCY.
>> THE U.S. HAS INDICTED HIM OR
FOUR TERROR-RELATED CHARGES
INCLUDING CONSPIRACY TO KILL
AMERICANS.
>> WHAT MAKES HIM A THREAT TO
THE UNITED STATES?
>> HE'S A SHADOW FACILITATOR.
HE'S ARMING NOTE ONLY DESIGNATED
TERRORIST GROUPS, INSURGENT
GROUPS BUT HE'S ALSO ARMING VERY
POWERFUL DRUG TRAFFICKING
CARTELS AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> TUCKER: SO THAT'S THE GUY
THAT JOE BIDEN JUST SPRUNG FROM
PRISON, THE INTERNATIONAL ARMS
DEALER WHO IS ARMING TERROR
GROUPS AND DRUG CARTELS.
THE SAME ADMINISTRATION WHO DID
THAT IS SPOILTLY CALLING FOR THE
ARREST AND IMPRISONMENT OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO HAVE
HANDGUNS OF MORE THAN 10 MOUNDS.
IT WAS A VERY COSTLY PRISONER
SWELL.
CERTAINLY FROM PAUL WHALEN'S
PERSPECTIVE IT WAS, EARLIER
TODAY, HE SPOKE TO A CNN
REPORTER FROM THE PENAL COLONY
WHERE HE'S BEING HELD SOUTH OF
MOSCOW.
LISTEN TO HIM.
>> I WOULD SAY IF A MESSAGE
COULD GO TO PRESIDENT BIDEN,
THIS IS A PRECARIOUS SITUATION
THAT NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED
QUICKLY, AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
HE AND HIS ADMINISTRATION WOULD
DO EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO GET
ME HOME REGARDLESS OF THE PRICE
THEY MAY HAVE TO PAY AT THIS
POINT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY I'M GREATLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT MORE HAS NOT
BEEN DONE TO SECURE MY RELEASE,
ESPECIALLY AS THE FOUR-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF MY ARREST IS
COMING UP.
I WAS ARRESTED FOR A CRIME THAT
NEVER OCCURRED.
I'M HAPPY THAT BRITTNEY GRINER
IS GOING HOME TODAY AND THAT
TREVOR WENT HOME WHEN HE DID BUT
BEYOND WHY I'M STILL SITTING
HERE.
MY BAGS ARE PACKED, I'M READY TO
GO HOME.
I JUST NEED AN AIRPLANE TO COME
AND GET ME.
>> TUCKER: POOR GUY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE'S
STILL SITTING HERE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW HE FEELS.
THE FORMER MARINE WHO HAS BEEN
THERE FOR FOUR YEARS ALREADY
GETS LEFT BEHIND IN RUSSIA WHILE
THE CELEBRITY ATHLETE GETS
BUSTED WITH HASH OIL, CHAMPIONED
BY HER CELEB MEDIA FRIENDS, IS
HOME IN JUST MONTHS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
IT SEEMS LIKE A METAPHOR FOR HOW
AMERICA UNDER JOE BIDEN IS
WORKING, BUT, NO SAYS JOE BIDEN.
WE HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO TAKE
BRITTNEY GRINER OVER PAUL
WHALEN.
PUTIN DEMANDED THAT.
>> WE'VE NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT
PAUL WHALEN WHO HAS BEEN
UNJUSTLY DETAINED IN RUSSIA FOR
YEARS.
THIS WAS NOT A CHOICE OF WHICH
AMERICAN TO BRING HOME.
>> TUCKER: THIS WAS NOT A CHOICE
OF WHICH AMERICAN TO BRING HOME.
REALLY?
IT CLEARLY WAS A CHOICE AND WE
KNOW IT WAS A CHOICE BECAUSE THE
FIRST ACCOUNTS OF THE PRISONER
SWAP WITH RUSSIA SAID IT WAS A
CHOICE.
EARLIER TODAY, ANDREA MITCHELL
OF NBC, THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO HAS
BEEN IN WASHINGTON COVERING NEWS
FOR MORE THAN 50 YEARS, SOMEONE
WHO IS DEEPLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
CONTRIBUTED TO A STORY THAT
CONTAINED THIS LINE.
"THE KREMLIN GAVE THE WHITE
HOUSE THE CHOICE OF EITHER
GRINER OR WHELAN OR NONE."
SO MITCHELL'S PIECE ATTRIBUTED
TO A SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL, IT
WAS NOT A GUESS, IT WAS SOURCED.
AND THEN, AS WITH THE EARLIER
REPORTING ON PAUL PELOSI LAST
MONTH, THAT ACCOUNT WAS
SCRUBBED.
THE KREMLIN ULTIMATELY GAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE THE CHOICE OF EITHER
GRINER OR NO ONE.
IN OTHER WORDS, JOE BIDEN'S
VERSION OF EVENTS IS NOW
PERFECTLY IN SYNC WITH THE
OFFICIAL NBC NEWS VERSION OF
EVENTS.
OF COURSE.
A WRITER ON STACKHOUSE NOTICED
IT AND WE'RE GLAD THAT HE DID.
THIS KIND OF THING HAPPENS ALL
THE TIME IN WASHINGTON, USUALLY
WITHOUT THE PUBLIC KNOWING THAT
IT HAPPENED.
SO AT THIS POINT, WE CAN ASSUME
THE OBVIOUS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CHOSE GRINER OVER
PAUL WHALEN.
THE BASKETBALL PLAYER OVER THE
MARINE FACING 16 YEARS.
THERE WAS ONLY ROOM FOR ONE, THE
LIFEBOAT, AND THE MARINE GOT
LEFT BEHIND.
WHY DID THEY MAKE THAT CHOICE?
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT WHALEN IS A
TRUMP VOTER AND HE MADE THE
MISTAKE OF SAYING SO ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND HE'S PAYING THE PRICE
NOW.
GRINER IS NOT.
DIFFERENT POLITICS.
SHE DESPISES THE US, SHE'S BEEN
VERY VOCAL ABOUT THAT.
THIS COUNTRY IS SO REBEL LENT
AND IMMORAL THAT TWO YEARS AGO
SHE SAID "I HONESTLY FEEL WE
SHOULD NOT PLAY THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM DURING OUR BASKETBALL
SEASON."
SHE HATES THE COUNTRY SO MUCH
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR ITS
ANTHEM.
THAT'S THE KIND OF POSITION THAT
GETS YOU REWARDED BY JOE BIDEN.
HATE AMERICA, PERFECT.
WE'LL FREE THE GUY THAT SOLD
WEAPONS TO DRUG CARTELS TO GET
YOU OUT EARLY.
THERE IS THAT, AND THEN THERE IS
THE MATTER OF IDENTITY, WHICH IS
CENTRAL TO EQUITY, SHE'S NOT
WHITE AND SHE'S A LESBIAN.
THEY MAY BE IRRELEVANT TO YOU
BUT THEY ARE NOT IRRELEVANT TO
THE PRESS SECRETARY.
THOSE ARE ESSENTIAL
QUALIFICATIONS FOR A PRISONER
SWAP.
WATCH?
>> IT CAME TO EITHER BRING
GRINER HOME OR NO ONE.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS
MORNING, HE'LL NEVER STOP
WORKING TO SECURE PAUL'S RELEASE
AND RETURN HOME, AND HE WILL NOT
GIVE UP.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE, BRITTNEY
GRINER IS MORE THAN AN ATHLETE,
MORE THAN AN OLYMPIAN, SHE'S AN
IMPORTANT ROLE MODEL AND
INSPIRATION TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, PARTICULARLY THE
LGBTI AND AMERICANS AND WOMEN OF
COLOR.
SHE SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
DETAINED BY RUSSIA.
>> TUCKER: SO THERE IS JOE
BIDEN'S PRESS SECRETARY TELLING
YOU THAT BRITTNEY GRINER IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE SHE'S A
LESBIAN WOMAN OF COLOR, AND BY
THE WAY, SO AM I.
HOW PERVERSE IS IT?
WELL, IMAGINE A PRESS SECRETARY
FROM THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
SAYING SEAN SPICER, PAUSING IN
THE MIDDLE OF A BRIEFING TO TELL
YOU, "ON A PERSONAL NOTE, IT IS
THRILLING WHEN A STRAIGHT WHITE
MAN GETS OUT OF PRISON."
WHAT WOULD YOU THINK OF THAT?
YOU WOULD PROBABLY SEE THAT AS
AN OFFENSE AGAINST THE IDEA OF
THE RULE OF LAW.
AGAINST THE IDEA OF A COUNTRY
WHERE WE'RE ALL TREATED EQUALLY
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL CITIZENS.
LIBERALS DON'T SEE THAT IT WAY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN
ABSTRACT PRINCIPLES SO THEY ARE
A HUNDRED PERCENT BEHIND THAT
IDEA.
HERE'S VAN JONES ON CNN.
>> IT JUST SHOWS THIS PRESIDENT
GOT IT DONE.
HE CARED ENOUGH ABOUT THIS
INDIVIDUAL PERSON TO GET HER
HOME.
IT WAS SHOCKING BUT I THINK FOR
YOUNG AMERICANS TO SEE AN ICON
LIKE THAT SNATCHED, LOCKED UP,
WHAT YOU DON'T HAVE AND WHAT YOU
CAN'T ALLOW TO HAPPEN, IS TO
HAVE A BLACK FEMALE ICON TREATED
LIKE GARBAGE AND FOR AMERICA TO
DO NOTHING ABOUT IT.
SOMETHING WAS DONE ABOUT IT AND
PEOPLE CAN BE PROUD ABOUT THAT.
>> TUCKER: YOU CAN'T HAVE AN
AMERICAN MISTREATED BY A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A BLACK FEMALE
ICON MISTREATED BY A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
YOU GET MORE RIGHTS BASED ON
WHAT COLOR YOU ARE A